entrée manuel Macron et volo dit
mirzuelenski les embrassades sont
chaleureuses le président ukrainien a
fait une étape surprise à Paris dimanche
soir pour un dîner de travail de trois
heures avec son homologue français pas
de grande déclarations politiques mais
une rencontre opérationnelle lors de
laquelle Paris annonce un nouveau
soutien militaire à Kiev dans les
semaines à venir la France formera à
équipea plusieurs batailles ont avec des
dizaines de véhicules blindés et de
charlés
dissertés en outre la France concentre
ses efforts sur le soutien des capacités
de défense aériennes de l'Ukraine afin
de défendre sa population contre les
frappes russes
volody mirzuelenski a entrepris ce
voyage en Europe pour mobiliser une fois
de plus ses dirigeants et récolter du
soutien et des armes
après un passage en Italie c'est en
Allemagne que zellens qui a trouvé le
plus de soutien lors d'une rencontre en
grande pompe avec le président Stan
Mayer et le chancelier au lave Scholtz
Berlin a promis une livraison d'armes
records signe du réchauffement des
relations entre les deux pays après des
mois difficiles au début de la guerre
je suis reconnaissant pour l'aide
militaire la plus importante que nous
ayons reçu depuis le début de l'invasion
russe
réussir qui s'élève à plus de 2
milliards 700 millions d'euros
c'est un soutien fort merci beaucoup
voilà
mais aucun pays n'affranchi la ligne
rouge tant espéré par volody mirzelenski
la livraison d'avions de combat et de
missiles qui permettrait de frapper les
lignes arrières russes en vue notamment
d'une contre-offensive d'envergure dans
l'est de l'Ukraine